the last Jedi delivers a new episode in
the Star Wars saga with some incredible
twists and turns and real shocks
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I want to discuss and delve
into the details of the ending of the
last Jedi reveals some Easter eggs and
deep cuts you might have missed and
explain what it all means for episode 9
the final film in this trilogy and to
celebrate the release for new Star Wars
movie I'm running a Star Wars giveaway
for all my subscribers to enter make
sure you're subscribed to my channel and
leave a comment below with your thoughts
about the last Jedi and I'll announce
the winner of my recent superhero
giveaway later in this video
spoiler warning obviously I'm discussing
the last Jedi in full detail so take
care if you haven't seen the movie yet
the final scenes in the movie are set on
crate where the resistance finds itself
holed up in an old rebel base their
shield door has been destroyed by the
first order siege cannon the first order
is amassed outside and there's no
apparent means of escape the resistance
is in a desperate situation as they
discover nobody is responding to their
distress signal assign that as Leia says
the Galaxy has lost all hope then out of
nowhere Luke appears and has a touching
reunion with his sister no one in the
resistance knows it yet but at this
point Lucas force projected himself out
of his own body which is still on act 2
Luke's force projection is able to
physically interact with events on crate
for example fighting kylo Ren in a
lightsaber duel while his physical body
is still on the island this is something
new we've not seen before in the Star
Wars movies however something similar
has been seen in the Star Wars Expanded
Universe aka Star Wars legends where
such projections are known as force
phantoms or Sith phantasms basically
they're apparitions created by
Darksiders aniseh that harnesses the
force energy from another being the
apparitions can then be projected across
the universe and used to interfere in
the physical realm and when the Phantom
is destroyed so is the life form which
supplied its force energy also in the
Star Wars dark empire comic books
Luke has created a projection of himself
in order to help Leia escape the Star
Wars legends universe is no longer canon
however but it's interesting to see
elements from it included with a twist
in the last Jedi given that force
projection is something new we're seeing
in the last year
I think we're likely to see more of it
going forward in new Star Wars movies
perhaps even with characters like Ray or
kylo Ren as their powers grow stronger
okay so getting back to that
confrontation on crates between Luke and
kylo Ren we need to analyze Luke's words
in more detail Luke tells kylo that the
rebellion is reborn today the war is
just beginning and I will not be the
last Jedi at this moment the camera cuts
to Rey who's discovered that the
resistance are stuck in the old rebel
base behind a pile of rocks Rey then
uses the force to move the rocks away
and given Luke's words we've got a clear
indication that Rey will be the face of
the new Jedi the moment is also a nice
callback to earlier in the movie when
Luke was teaching Rey about the force
and explained that it's not about
lifting rocks which itself was a
reference to the Empire Strikes Back
when Luke trained with Yoda when the
scene cuts back to Luke and kylo facing
off kylo vows to destroy everyone and in
a moment that's very reminiscent of
obi-wan Kenobi and Darth Vader in a new
hope
Luke turns off his lightsaber and says
to kylo strike me down in anger and I'll
always be with you just like your father
and as Luke disappears from Krait we cut
back to the island where Luke is
levitating the effort of the force
projection though causes Luke to
collapse back onto the rock we then get
a very emotional scene as Luke looks out
across the water and a cloud passes over
the Sun then Luke vanishes leaving
behind just his robes becoming one with
the force in the same way that obi-wan
vanished when Darth Vader struck him
down in a new hope and also how Yoda
passed away in Return of the Jedi Luke
sacrificed to save the resistance
allowing them to escape the first order
also mirrors obi-wan sacrifice which
allowed Han Leia and Luke to escape
Vader this is a heartbreaking scene for
many fans but there's some important
visual symbolism here to Luke's
sacrifice brought some balance back as
the first order was about to snuff out
the resistance before his intervention
and the cloud partially obscuring the
Sun suggests the light and the darkness
in some sort of balance at one point in
the sequence what looked like a faint
rainbow appeared in the sky not only can
rainbows be a sign of hope change in a
bridge between worlds was also in the
Buddhist tradition a rainbow body as a
state of enlightenment when a person
achieves the highest
of meditation and complete knowledge and
is often said to happen around the time
of death with the body dissolving into
light the Jedi way and Star Wars borrows
from various Eastern traditions and
philosophies one of which is Buddhism so
I think the rainbow symbolism goes
perfectly with the idea of Luke having
reached a higher state with his ability
to force project himself and then when
he becomes one with the force at the end
later in the scene we also see two sons
on the horizon which is another
nostalgic call back to when Luke walked
out on Tatooine in a new hope and looked
out over the sunset I'm pretty sure Luke
will return in episode 9 though most
likely as a force ghost with an ongoing
ability to participate and influence
events Yoda already came back as a force
ghost in the last Jedi and set the
forestry on fire and I think we could
see Luke have new scenes with Rey and
kylo in the next movie after all his
parting words to kylo were see you
around kid this death was sensed by Ray
and Leia and although as a poignant
moment ray does say that she didn't
sense sadness or pain but peace and
purpose however that still leaves Rey
wondering at the end how they will
rebuild the resistance Leia answers that
they have everything they need and the
camera pans down to Rey holding Luke's
old lightsaber which was split in two
earlier in the movie when she struggled
with kylo Ren for control of it inside
one of the lightsaber halves you can see
an exposed Kyber crystal although Kyber
crystals have appeared in other Star
Wars media in the movies who were first
introduced in Rome one where the Empire
was amassing them for the construction
of the Death Star Kyber crystals are a
crucial element in constructing
lightsabers as they help to concentrate
energy into the weapons blade in the
animated Clone Wars TV series new Jedi
younglings have been involved in
gathering Kyber crystals to build their
own lightsabers and so I think layers
words along with the visual of the Kyber
crystal indicate we could see ray start
a new jedi academy to fight back against
the first order or perhaps the Kyber
crystals will be key to some new
resistance technology that we've not yet
seen in the Star Wars universe in a
similar way to how they were crucial to
the Empire and operating the Death Star
super weapon by the way just before Rey
boarded the Millennium Falcon she and
Kyla were still able to sense each other
earlier Snoke claimed that he was
Barnesville for bridging kylo and raise
minds but with Snoke dead by the end of
the movie it seems that either Snoke was
manipulating and lying to them and all
kylo and Rey's abilities have increased
and so they can now connect with each
other independent of anyone else however
the way Rey closes the Millennium Falcon
door during their final connection might
mean she's closing off future
communication with kylo well though we
see kylo continue to embrace the dark
side throughout the last Jedi he is
still conflicted for example hesitating
to kill his mother Leia and I wonder if
given that Luke told layer no one's ever
really gone we may see kylo redeem
himself in some way by the end of
episode 9 as Darth Vader did by the end
of Return of the Jedi though if this did
happen I'd expect that to be a spin on
it to make it at least a bit different
of course Luke's line that no one's ever
really gone also refers to Han Solo and
Luke hands Leia the dice from the
Millennium Falcon just after saying this
but Luke's words also foreshadow his own
sacrifice at the end of the movie and
his likely return in episode 9 before we
leave crate we need to talk about Finn
and rose in contrast to his attempt to
lead the resistance early on in the film
Finn ends up willing to sacrifice
himself with a cause when he speeds
towards the first orders mega cannon and
although I never really believed that
Episode eight would be the end for Finn
director Rian Johnson did manage to rack
up the tension but Rose drops in
literally crashing his speeder off
course and then unexpectedly kisses him
it's interesting that Finn and roses
last major scene together calls back to
their first scene which also featured
Rose scuffering Finn's plans when she
stopped him leaving in an escape pod but
a lots changed since then and finis
stepped up proving worthy of roses high
opinion of him as a hero and Rose
herself as proven worthy of the title
hero as well and roses line to Finn that
they should win by saving what they love
not by fighting what they hate was a
positive moment amid a bleak situation
for the resistance and echos what Luke
was taught by Yoda and obi-wan about not
giving in to hate I wasn't necessarily
expecting the movie to pair up Rose and
Finn but given they did it's a nice
touch that she ends a film healing up
similar to how fin finished his story in
the force awakens so those were the
final scenes with the main cast but just
before the credits roll we get an
important short scene set back on Kanto
bite where we see the stable hands
reenacting the events on crate with
their own handmade toys the scene shows
that news and stories of how the
legendary Jedi Master stood up to kylo
Ren in the first order have spread
through the galaxy
reigniting a spark that will light the
fire to burn the first order down as PO
dam run says at the end of the movie in
an echo vice-admiral hold those words
one of the boys then goes outside and as
he's force-sensitive he calls a broom to
him then looks up and sees a streak of
light flash across the sky we can then
see that he's wearing the old rebellion
ring that Rose Tico gave him earlier in
the movie it's a moment filled with hope
and confirms Luke's claim to kylo Ren
that the rebellion is reborn by the way
according to the visual dictionary the
boy's name appears to be tamiri black
and I wonder whether he will actually be
a specific new force user who will
appear in either episode 9 or the new
trilogy that Rian Johnson's developing
after JJ Abrams film if he is going to
appear again then we may well revisit
canto bite in a future movie also I
think it's intriguing that this boy like
Rey has been sold and abandoned by his
parents which means we're guessing a
theme in Star Wars that a force user
doesn't always need to inherit their
force abilities from a special or
privileged family this scene also hints
that we may get a time jump between the
end of the last Jedi in episode 9
this would allow time for stories to
spread about Luke Skywalker and the
resistance and how they foiled the first
order a time gap could also be a
possible way to deal with Leia's story
in episode 9 and the fact that Carrie
Fisher is so sadly no longer with us and
if you're interested in my thoughts and
theories on how I think we'll see layers
are completed in the sequel then tap in
the top right or check the video
description for my Carrie Fisher video
so what did you think about the last
Jedi and did it live up to your
expectations and do you have any
predictions on what you think we'll see
in episode 9
leave me a comment below and be sure to
subscribe to end my Star Wars giveaway
for a very cool last Jedi Funko pop the
winner of my latest superhero giveaway
is on screen right now so if that's you
send me a private message so I can get
your prize out to you coming up I've got
more last Jedi videos so turn on
notifications to get them as soon as I
upload them and in the means
you can check out some more videos
you're sure to like right here thanks
for watching and see you next time you
became movie lovers